a pretty good receiver in new england in
the form of julian edelman he won the
super bowl 53 mvp award we spent a lot
of time talking during the show about
ped use whether or not julian edelman
has ever been truly accountable has he
ever been pressed on what he took why he
took it and did he know he was cheating
that he was taking something at the time
he took it that was a violation of the
ped policy or was it like so many other
guys who say well you know i hey i just
took a supplement that was spiked with
something he's never been pressed to
answer that i think that that his
silence is deafening in that regard and
tells me he did know what he was doing
he did take a ped in order to accelerate
his recovery from that torn acl he
suffered in the 2017 preseason but chris
look
you made a good point maybe the nfl and
the nflpa should negotiate a small range
of injuries for which certain types of
peds are permissible to allow that
recovery process to happen faster so the
guys can get back on the field right
they take all sorts of other crap that
isn't a ped to get back on the field
prescription pain killers etc
maybe there are some things a small
category narrow range of things that god
can take okay fine negotiate that how
about show that you give a crap about
cheating though and at the same time
you're negotiating that let's make the
punishment more stringent for a guy who
does test positive and how about this do
what baseball does you get four games
and you don't get to play in the
playoffs right that's something you've
said several times as it relates to
julian edelman maybe that's what the
punishment should be and without that
kind of a punishment is it a surprise
that people don't care about ped use
more than 50
in the poll question that we posted
today don't care it doesn't seem like
the nfl cares it seems like it's just
checking a box it's not nearly the
punishment that it should be for
cheating the game cheating the sport
yeah taking a substance that
artificially makes you bigger faster
stronger than you otherwise would be
yeah right well and then julian edelman
case is certainly not going to scare
anybody away from doing it oh oh i can
take it i lose four games and then be
celebrated after the season oh you were
a great playoff run you win the super
bowl mvp and just everybody celebrates
them and you know i mean the gosh there
was talk there member of the super bowl
week is julian edelman a hall of famer
and i was like my brain was blowing up i
mean whoa and again i don't know to what
extent did he take it to get healthy was
he taking this for performance levels i
don't know all that i want to think he
was taking him to be healthy but
regardless at the end of the day like
you're saying he cheated these are the
rules they are right now and it's unfair
to the other people who did it the right
way to try to heal from injuries or if
he was trying to get better it's unfair
fair to the you know the players who are
doing it the right way too and just
going out there and drinking protein
shakes and working hard and doing it
that way too to where i go you're
cheating a lot of people uh a lot as
well as that but you know
i am shocked that people don't care as
much as they do uh i know it really
bothers me but to what you said first
too mike i you know i agree i just think
you know hopefully we can find a way
the the the the suspension of the
playoff thing i think should happen you
got to hit these players harder you
either got to hit them harder with a
playoff suspension or something more
games or you got to make the what you
tested positive for in the pd scale uh
you need to make it public to give
players the fear of embarrassment right
i think that would certainly stop some
players to go oh i can't use the i
accidentally took something from gnc
that i didn't know about yeah sure go
kiss my butt with those excuses i'm so
sick of that crap um
but but i do want to find a fine line
rare for torn acl torn achilles torn
patella tendon you know
maybe it's a month after the surgery
you're allowed to take these pd's to
help accelerate the process of rehabbing
and getting people back to their
strength because it is their profession
and uh it is how they're making a living
as well
yeah and look i i i can get behind the
idea of expanding the list or narrowing
the list rather banned substances under
certain circumstances but you know on
that la on on one of the points you made
in that last response the idea that
there is a difference between
recovering from an injury versus just
trying to get better do you believe that
it's different because in my mind it's
the same ped uses ped use there is no
exception currently right for recovering
from injury now maybe there should be
under certain circumstances but you know
over 60 percent of the people who
responded to our other question today
see a difference between using a ped to
recover from an injury versus you and
using a ped just to go get bigger faster
and stronger it's the same thing folks
well it's cheating regardless as the way
it's laid out right now but i think what
players are saying i mean what the
people i i would guess are saying or at
least my thought of this is yeah i do
look at it as a little differently i
mean
yeah i do i mean if you're if you're
really banged up and hurt and you you
needed to take a ped to help to
strengthen the ligaments and do all that
yes within the rules of the letter of
the law right now i know it's cheating
but i look at that as less egregious
right than the guy who's totally healthy
and it's you know it's march april may
june and he's just given himself more
hgh or more whatever it is and he's
getting all of a sudden he went from
four five four to now he's four four
nine and he weighs 15 or 20 pounds more
and he can squat 100 pounds more and he
can bench press another 50 pounds that's
where i go no that's just crazy that's
bs you're cheating you're breaking laws
now you're you're endangering other
people on the football field because
you're excessively bigger and stronger
than you should be and it's not fair to
the guys that are also endangering
themselves i i do think the reason we
see these like non-contact acl injuries
at times is because i go guys are just
they're bigger and stronger than their
body was intended to be at times and i
go that's why your knee gave out and i
think hgh can play a role into that with
performance-enhancing drugs with guys
being too strong or too big or too
powerful for what their body was really
made to be
here's the bottom line the rule is
currently very clear there is a specific
list of substances that players are
prohibited from taking and it is a
strict liability standard if the
substance is in your body if it is
detected in that urine test you are
tested positive you have violated the
policy and you are suspended for games
and the thing that irritates me more
than anything else is that you know
under the excuses we've heard over the
last 30 years they've never caught an
actual deliberate cheater right every
guy well i didn't realize what i was
taking okay how can it be that every guy
that ever gets caught says that that
means they've never actually caught
someone who actually was consciously
deliberately cheating and it could be
that julian edelman is the closest thing
to that because he's the one guy who
hasn't come out and said he got a bad
supplement somewhere he's just basically
said nothing right which maybe says
everything yeah right i think it does it
says it all he never tried to bs or make
an excuse i mean i could still remember
a thing right before the season where
they was asked about it and he just
looked and said i don't know which i
meant you do know and you knew you were
wrong and he just felt really bad about
it and you don't want to talk about it
and uh you know again i i want to root
for julian edelman but this certainly
has made me second-guess things for sure
and you know i've already put out poll
question number three now a lot of times
the early results are indicative of what
the ultimate results will be 500 votes
so far just in the last two minutes i
asked this question should players who
violate the ped policy be suspended four
games and banned from postseason play
like baseball already 65 say no wow
people just don't care people chris i
think the the fans it's baked in the
idea that there's no way that football
players are that big that strong that
fast come back from injuries that
quickly unless there's pharmaceutical
enhancement and we're just okay with it
for as as okay as we aren't with it in
baseball we are okay with it in football
yeah i know and again this is the big
you know i know we talked about this in
the show how many guys do we really feel
like are doing in the nfl and i seem to
be a little naive and low when i talk to
people i always go uh maybe you know
five six seven guys on a team i know you
think it's more i know there's a lot of
ex players that i talk about that i
think are more you know i think you know
to your point where the general public
goes oh man
how could they be this big and strong
you know i don't know maybe i'm
different too but i grew up around it i
played you know football and at the
university of texas you know a lot of
these times these guys that i see are
big and strong you know why they're big
and strong
do you know why they're big and strong
no thank you why are you listening are
you talking i i didn't know you're
waiting for no i didn't know i thought i
thought you you know you know that
that's how normal human conversation
works hey do you know why i did that
i'll tell you why yeah tell me i didn't
know that you were expecting dialogue
there why thank you such good dialogue
right there
because their parents are giant humans
too you know that's the one thing you
know i don't you know think gets glossed
over it you've watched the nfl draft
before okay i mean gosh i see moms and
dads on the carpet sometimes and i go
whoa you know mom might be able to play
middle linebacker and dad might be able
to play defense end and i'm not trying
to say that to be disrespectful but you
know that's why the son is a giant human
being and a physical freak because his
parents are too but i don't know what to
think with this whole thing it's tough i
got i got one last point to make i don't
think you're naive regarding the extent
to which peds were used yeah i think the
locker room generally and i mean this is
a compliment yeah
unless it comes out as an insult but
i'll still say i mean it is a compliment
i think they pegged you as a guy who who
was not going to participate and was not
going to condone
and if you saw something you were going
to say something not that you were going
to be a snitch per se right but i think
they could read that you were a guy that
wasn't going to mess with it and you
weren't going to be happy about it if
anybody was doing it so hey it's we we
got we got to keep this away we can't
let chris know we're doing this
i think they figured i they think they
figured out they were gonna have a real
problem if you knew what was going on i
don't deny that mike i i'd have been the
guy that in the locker room that prob
you know i mean probably i did i mean
you know uh you know i i would speak out
about these type of matters and being
like that's bs if i were shocked yeah
you know i'm shocked to know that
there's a reason brandon stokely called
me the uh you know s-h-i stirrer he used
to call me that he goes oh gosh here
comes the stir he's coming into the
locker room because he knew i was going
to stir up some good conversation
well that's why i'm glad you're part of
what we're doing now we got one more day
before our four-week hiatus chris you're
gonna miss me more than you realize now
even if you are running for the eggs
it's one more day for you two more days
for me we'll be back thursday with
another edition of pft live in pftot
great work today chris we'll talk we'll
talk again tomorrow see you man
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports